the people who win work the hardest
because they love what they do if you
just focus on the money you're never
gonna get it this is what so many
entrepreneurs do and why so many
entrepreneurs fail is their number one
goal is money your perfectionism is
killing you it's preventing you from
doing amazing things in your life and
with the business the motivation watch
top talent believe nation what's that
believe nation it's Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you grab a snack
ensure today's lessons from me I'm Evan
Carmichael and here's my take on my top
ten roses access vol 3
also if you want to know what myself and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confident series where every day for the
next 254 days I will send you a morning
video for free to help you build your
confidence the link to join is in the
description below if you're doing work
that you love you're more likely to
follow through you're more likely to do
it because it doesn't feel like work
because you love doing it surround
yourself with greatness if you want to
be more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one work the hardest the people who win
work the hardest because they love what
they do
they put in the hours and the hours any
hours and the hours for days and days
and days and weeks and weeks and weeks
and months and months and months years
and years and years because they love it
because it's not worked for them the
only way you're going to be willing to
put in the work that is necessary to win
to be the best in your industry the only
way you're gonna put in that amount of
work is because you love what you're
doing and if you don't you're gonna
you're gonna lose cuz there's gonna be
somebody who will love it who loves it
more than you and will crush you and
you'll be not even a number two you'll
be mediocre because there's lots of
people who love what they do and there's
less people grinding it and working hard
if you are looking at your calendar like
open up your account look what you're
gonna do today or look what you're doing
tomorrow what's on the schedule if
you're looking at it and you're like oh
I got to do all these things if that's
your reaction you might be in the wrong
business now if it's a one-off thing if
there's a one day you know you got to
deal with the government or something
fine
but if that's daily if that's consistent
if that's always happening if you
continue to look at your calendar and
you're you're upset and depressed and
angry you're in the wrong business the
work should feel like something exciting
to go and do where other people might
jump into your schedule and say that's
crazy I could never do that that's great
that's why you're not crushing it like I
am like go go crush it in your field go
do your thing
rule number two create your own path I
think too many people are trying to live
someone else's path you're trying to
follow your parents path you're trying
to be the next Michael Jordan or the
next wing Gretzky or the next Steve Jobs
you're trying to be the next somebody
else where if your goal is to be the
next somebody else you're always gonna
fall short you can't out Steve Steve
it's not happening it's not going to be
possible so you will always fall short
if you are trying to follow somebody
else's path the key is to create your
own unique path
that's where you're gonna stand out and
that's where the magic is gonna happen
you already are unique you already are
the first and only version of you that
will ever walk this planet that has
already happened but you're not the best
you yet you're the unique you you're the
first you but you're not the best you
yet and that's where you can pull from
people you can pull from jobs you can
pull from updates and you can pull from
Winfrey and you can pull from LeBron you
can pull from all these people to make
you the best version of you and help you
go off on your path and it starts by
understanding what your one word is
living your life on purpose knowing what
your values are and having the
self-awareness to create something that
is important and then by embracing the
genius at the end we're the unique
talents that you have it matched up
together in a way that nobody else can
execute on and it often counts why I
want to do this or I want to do this
or I want to do this and you've got two
or three or four things that you don't
know which direction to take and the
real answer is to smash all of those
things together
because that's the unique thing that
only you can do anybody can be a banker
anybody can be a salsa dancer anybody
can be a gamer
anybody can be a fill-in-the-blank but
when you start combining those things
together and then combine it with your
one word which is your value system
that's something that nobody else can do
is something nobody else can touch now
you're off creating your own path and
being the best version of you and that's
where your ultimate success happiness
wealth and impact will come create your
own path rule number three builds
self-discipline the mind is getting in
your own way if you want to lose weight
you know how to do it you got to eat
less you gotta work out more you will
lose weight why are you not doing it
self discipline your mind is getting in
your way what I see self discipline is a
positive I think self discipline has a
really negative connotation a lot of
times I think in a lot of the messages
that people are putting out it comes
across as this really negative thing
like you have to force yourself to do
all of the stuff that you really hate
and it's gonna suck but you have to keep
going you got to do it you got to be
disciplined if you're not disciplined
you suck everything's terrible it just
comes across as those really
negative forcing yourself to do stuff
that doesn't resonate with me
I see self-discipline as a really
positive thing I think it's really
helpful I think it's amazing and
beautiful and golden let's look at
weight as an example I am the lowest
weight that I've been all year I'm on a
routine it's working the specific
strategies that don't really matter
one intimate it fasting so I'll only
have water and a coffee until noon and
then after that I'll start eating I do
that seven days a week I run for thirty
minutes usually at night while I'm
watching the show with my wife seven
days a week and then six days a week
I'll restrict my calories not really
forcing myself not to eat food just not
eating Doritos and not eating junk right
eating healthy food six days a week and
then Saturdays I get to do what I want
six days a week those are the strategies
that I use it may seem like torture but
it's not and the thing that helps me get
through it is the mindset because the
positive of all of this is I'm losing
weight I'm feeling great I'm making
progress I'm super-pumped that I'm
getting closer to my goal I feel amazing
about myself so I think self-discipline
usually it seems to focus just on the
action that you just have to grind your
way through it without and not focus on
the mission of what you're trying to
accomplish and how beautiful and
wonderful that is and so yes some of it
might suck right but you're moving
toward something amazing and beautiful
so I think people just focus too much on
the negative part of it and and if you
force yourself to do something that you
hate you can only do it for so long
before you give up if you can't tie it
into the bigger picture of what you're
trying to accomplish then you will give
up and you will quit and you will feel
terrible and then I think having other
people yell at you but how you need to
have self-discipline doesn't actually
help I think it actually makes it worse
because you develop the identity for
yourself of I don't have any
self-discipline you can build it it's
not that difficult to do in my
perspective in my view all you need to
do is make sure that you have a really
strong why make sure that you have an
outcome that you are really looking
forward to and you love doing and then
the process itself how do you make the
process as enjoyable as possible how do
you make the process just not absolutely
suck
single-day going in right if you figure
that out then you win rule number four
don't focus on the money if you just
focus on the money you're never gonna
get it this is what so many
entrepreneurs do and why so many
entrepreneurs fail is their number one
goal is money now money is important if
you're running a business money is
important you know even if you're
running a charity money's still
important money is important it's just
not the number one thing it's number two
or three there has to be something more
important than money for you to have
success ultimate success as an
entrepreneur sure you can make a few
bucks but you look at the people at the
top in any field money was never the
number-one goal look at the people who
are self-made millionaires and
billionaires and read their biographies
and read their story and understand why
they started their companies watch the
top ten videos on all of them it's never
been about the money it's always been
about making a profound change for the
way something is done in their industry
having a deep passion for their craft
that they needed to bring this thing out
into creation you know when George Lucas
created Star Wars he thought it would be
a flop he thought it would only be for a
select few geeks who really loved that
genre he never expected it to be this
huge thing that turned him into a
billionaire but he loved making
immediately poured every ounce of
creativity had into making that that
movie and that's a story over and over
and over and over and over again
successful entrepreneurs love their
craft they want to do the work and as a
result of creating something valuable
because they put so much love into it
then they start making money rule number
five start now there is no perfect first
step there is no perfect plan there is
no perfect time to get started a lot of
people are so held up on finding what
the perfect first thing is to do that
they do nothing and that's the ultimate
failure the ultimate failure is doing
nothing and just sitting on this idea
I've never taken any kind of action for
it because you're worried about making
misstep you're worried about making
mistake you're worried that it's not
perfect your perfectionism is killing
you it's preventing you from doing
amazing things in your life and with the
business you take any step you have a
vision
is what I want to accomplish here's my
goal I want to write a book I want to
start a company I want to whatever it is
whatever first step comes to my goal and
do that and then adjust adjust adjust
adjust you can have the best plan in the
world right and I'm all for business
planning it's not just I'm just gonna
throw an idea out there and see what
happens right you can plan you can model
success you can look at what has worked
for people but you have to go out and do
it because the best plan is obsolete as
soon as you start executing on it and
this is what almost killed my first
business this is how I learned the
lesson because I was that guy I was the
perfectionist I didn't want to do
anything so I had it all figured out and
you only later realize that what you
think you figured out you have no idea
what you're talking about because you
haven't gone out and done anything yet I
lost a 40 million dollar deal in my
first company I was making $300 a month
sucking in my company turned it around
started making an income and had an
opportunity to sell my business for 40
million dollars I lost it to my biggest
competitor because I had to have the
perfect plan because I spent an entire
summer working on the perfect plan and I
was too late to the table I was looking
the wrong way
what made great sense on paper wasn't
actually what was gonna happen in the
market and I lost a 40 million dollar
dude because of it that kills that sucks
I was 22 years old it's important to
plan what you need to do and don't get
so hung up on having the perfect step
don't worry what the first step is
people write in and say what's my first
it doesn't matter something do something
and then do something again tomorrow and
do something again the next day and
every day you get a little bit better
start taking massive action that's how
you're gonna get that idea out of your
head
finally and out into the world's you can
start reaping the benefits and having a
big impact on this world like you are
meant to do rule number six find mentors
I'm a big believer in mentorship one in
terms of you know face to face people
that you can go and learn from and to
from what I call aspirational Mentors
people who've done a lot more than you
who you may never meet who may have
passed on but you can still learn from
their success it comes from the core
understanding that whatever challenge
you have in front of you right now
somebody else has already solved it
whatever big problem you're facing in
your life or in your business somebody
has already solved it and you don't need
to come up with every ingenious solution
yourself this is one of the things that
saved my first business one of the two
most important lessons that I've ever
learned in my life was whenever I don't
know what to do we never have a big
problem I don't know the answer I look
for somebody who has already solved it
and I try to learn from their lessons in
my first business I had a software
company I was struggling you know making
$300 a month barely able to survive and
I was just trying to come up with all
these ideas myself like okay how about
we do this how do we do this how many
and nothing was working and I told my
partner I quit and it was the worst day
of my life and when I woke up the next
day I realized I didn't want to quit I
just couldn't keep going the way I was
going and the light bulb moment was I
realized I'm not the first guy to try to
sell software before maybe our specific
kind of software yes but in general
other people have figured out how to
sell software and make lots of money and
target lots of customers how did they do
it and I looked at Bill Gates and how he
got started and that started the process
to me be able to build a real company
and that lesson that I learned that 19
years old has stayed true for the past
almost 20 years where every time I don't
know what to do and look at who can I
model it's it's why the name of this
channel is modeling the Masters it's why
I try to showcase lots of different
successful people from all walks of life
because you can learn from them I'm
learning from that rule number seven
dream big it can be hard to keep
perspective when you hit a rough patch
it can be hard to stay sane and stay
motivated stay optimistic when you fall
on tough times when something doesn't go
right when the market slows down when
you lose a big customer and that's part
of the game of being an entrepreneur
we're gonna have these highs and lows
but hopefully we're moving forward in
the positive direction and part of
winning as an entrepreneur is just
sticking with it it's just staying on
the path it's just every day getting up
and being consistent and moving forward
you only really lose if you give up
right and so you can lose little battles
but if you keep going you're gonna win
the war and I think what really helps
you keep consistent and keep motivated
and keep on every day getting up and
fighting is remembering the whys
remembering your big dream the big goal
what you're trying to accomplish and so
for me I think about untapped potential
you know I think the biggest problem in
the world is untapped human potential I
think if we can solve that we solve all
the major problems of the world and I
think the way to help untap people or
help to unlock them help bring out that
potential is through the environment
right you may not have that with your
friends and your family your parents the
people around you but you can get that
from the books and videos and the
resources that you watching consume and
so it's why I created this YouTube
channel so what keeps me motivated on a
daily basis is thinking about that big
problem the biggest problem the world is
facing is untapped human potential and
if I can create content that slowly
moves people forward slowly helps unlock
a little bit of potential if you keep
hearing the same message multiple times
from different people slowly it starts
to seep in right the more time you spend
around successful people the more you
want to become successful the more you
adopt their mindset and positivity and
the more you hang around people who are
not accomplishing things who are
complaining and who are negative the
more you're gonna be like those people
and so my solution is to create that for
you for myself I want to be around Buber
successful people and have their mindset
seep into me rule number eight make the
most of every opportunity you need to
hustle while you wait if you can embody
this advice and apply it to your
business on a day to day basis this will
be the biggest momentum shift in your
company this will move you so close to
your goals at an incredible pace that is
unbelievable just most people don't do
it hustle while you wait
listen with every goal that you have it
relies on other people you need other
people to be a part of your process
right if you're selling to customers you
need the customer to say yes they have
to make their decision there's a
back and forth if you're waiting on a
product to come you're waiting on your
supplier to come forward this there's
always things that are outside your
control that you're waiting other people
for and yes when it comes to you you
want to get it done as soon as possible
if a customer is asking for a quote you
want to get it off your plate ASAP you
should not be the bottleneck in momentum
happening in your business that's a
whole other problem as soon as that that
comes to you it's getting taken care of
and you're building momentum but you're
still even at the most peak efficiency
waiting for other people to take action
that's gonna happen so what do you do in
those moments you hustle you build new
momentum you build new clients you build
new relationships you maintain the
existing ones and get everything done as
soon as possible and then in the
downtime while you're waiting for a
decision
you're not just twiddling your thumbs
you're not just sitting on the couch
you're not watching Netflix you're off
hustling new business quick example I
was doing a photo shoot with Richard
this guy's a celebrity photographer he's
done lady gaga done the whole bunch of
rappers he came over and we did a photo
shoot together and in between his shots
he's gotta set up lights he's gotta get
his fog machine going he's got to get
the right angle it's got to set up the
green-screen
and so when he needs me I'm there I'm
ready I'm posing I'm in action I'm ready
to go but there's a lot of setup
in-between shots and so what am i doing
I'm pulling out my phone and I'm
responding to you guys I'm making videos
I'm doing responses I'm getting on
Twitter and Instagram I'm doing on
snapchat
I'm sending out video responses to you
guys I'm working I'm hustling on my down
time while I'm looting for rich for this
project I am hustling connecting with
you guys and that's the approach that
you need to take people say well how do
I find the time to respond to people on
social media I'd probably have a way
bigger cats and you guys do and I find
the time because I make the time in
between the other things that I'm doing
this is so critical people are losing so
much time the answer is not to wake up
two hours early or think that's gonna
solve your problem the answer is you're
using time every single day you are
leaking valuable time from your daily
schedule and so I highly highly highly
encourage you to take this message home
while you are working while people are
waiting on you for stuff you are doing
your best to deliver as soon as possible
so that you are not the bottleneck in
your business but then while you're
awaiting other people you get your
hustle on you continue to build momentum
it is such a hack to get you closer to
achieving the goals that you have for
yourself stop sleeping while you're
waiting for the people to get back to
you hustle while you wait
rule number nine always be positive I
love the idea of reframing a negative
situation into a positive one it can
really serve you it reminds me of what
Tony Robbins said of you look at the
worst thing that's ever happened to your
life and ask yourself how can this worst
thing ever be the best thing ever
how do you reframe it so that the most
negative situation ever in your life
becomes your biggest strength becomes
your mission helps you follow something
that then have the bigger impact I
really think that for people who get
through a negative situation it makes
them a lot stronger just as a human
being and quite often the mission that
we have in our lives with things that we
want to contribute and give back is so
that other people don't have to face the
same consequences the same suffering
that we faced so for me I love helping
entrepreneurs I love it it fuels me it
drives me what's the big reason for it
was because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur that I want to make it
easier for other people who are like me
and if you're looking for your mission
just go back to previous pain that you
deal with and how you've gotten through
it quite often what you want to do is it
is then make it easier for people to not
have to suffer through the same pain
figure out what you stand for figure
what your one word is figure out what's
at the core of you figure out what your
mission is and then it'll make it a
situation that happens you can really
frame it to one that's empowering for
you the one that serves you the ones
that builds you up and can inspire
others around you as well and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is do not be afraid
of failure if you want to succeed then
you need to adjust
failures gonna happen if you look at the
most successful people in the world
we've studied them where in the book
they're all over the channel they feel
the most the most successful person and
you look up to these like wow that
person is so successful I can't believe
it they have failed way more than you
even try not everything works out most
of the series that I put out on this
channel don't work out we test
constantly and most of them never go
anywhere they just don't get enough
traction there's an experiment you
failed we move on to the next one we
have failed more than most people even
try and that's why we succeed and that's
a consistent habit around people who are
winning they win because they tried so
many other things and a certain
percentage make their way through and
most people are so afraid to fail but
they don't even try and that's the
biggest failure of all they're so afraid
of it not working out there but not
being the big hit but they just sit on
their idea and then they watch somebody
else make tons of money you have a huge
impact from it get it out there may not
be the biggest version of what you're
trying to do but start start small build
momentum see if you still even like this
thing or not see if you can get some
people interested in our line and expect
to fail failure is not the enemy
failure is normal failure is welcomed
right you're gonna learn from it you're
gonna build on it you're gonna make it
better if you are not feeling if you're
winning every time think about it like
if you're winning every time everything
you touch wins that means you're playing
a tiny game it means you're racing
against three-year-olds great
congratulations you want every single
race because you're running against
three-year-olds if you want to be the
best you want to have an impact you want
to make your business a success you want
to make money you want to reach people
you do not have to race against people
who are a little more skilled and
talented you're gonna have to risk
losing you're not gonna win every race
but the good news is you don't have to
you don't have to win every race to
succeed you just have to win one you can
run a hundred races you just need to win
one and then they call you an overnight
success
now I've got a special bonus tip from me
on how to be stubborn on your vision
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life or business
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what is your big
dream number two what failure are you
afraid of that you need to let go of and
number three what will you start right
now
you need to be insanely stubborn about
the mission insanely stubborn about the
why you're doing things but really
flexible about the how and I think you
need to have that stubbornness
especially as an entrepreneur because
when you're getting started you're gonna
get so much pushback right what you
create your product your service won't
be really great at the start and so
it'll be hard to get people to buy from
you you'll have people around you
friends family coworkers you know people
in your community telling you that it's
not gonna work out you're telling
yourself that sometimes this is crazy
and it's not gonna work out and so
everything around you is saying that
this is crazy and that maybe it's not
the smartest thing to do right being an
entrepreneur is really the smart thing
to do it might be the best thing to do
but what we do is we create a world that
does not exist like the best
entrepreneurs have a vision for a world
that they want to create that doesn't
exist yet so from a practical
perspective it doesn't make sense like
we're doing something that has never
been done before you guys need to be
doing something has never been done
before
right like you can model some success
but at some point you have to find your
own path and when you go and create your
own path it's not practical it's not
logical because it doesn't exist yet you
have to go and create it and so you need
to have that stubbornness for the
mission for the vision for what end
objective you're trying to create
because of all of the pushback and
negativity and zero progress you're
gonna make at the beginning if you don't
have that stubbornness if you aren't
willing to say no this is gonna work out
to yourself and to the people around you
who are naysayers then you're gonna quit
which most entrepreneurs end up doing
they they quit they don't have enough
stubbornness for where they want to go
the flexibility that was about how you
go and accomplish it I want to make this
world better here's how I want it to
look like here's here's what I want to
change in the industry but how you go
out and do it should be flexible and
this is where I think too many
entrepreneurs are too stubborn it has to
be this specific way and this way only
so you spend all this time making this
perfect plan right the perfectionist you
want to make this perfect plan and
you're all your time was working on this
plan and this is exactly how it's going
to
playout no matter how much planning you
do it's never gonna go according to that
plan every successful business look at
how they started it's not how they
started that led them to their ultimate
success sometimes it's a radical shift
in their plan sometimes it's a minor
shift in their playing but it always has
to change just look at any company look
at how they started look at Starbucks
they started selling just beans you
couldn't get coffee going into a
Starbucks they would only sell you the
beans
BMW started selling airplanes that's why
their logo is an airplane propeller
you know Wrigley's the gun company
started selling other household products
and gum was just used as a as a giveaway
that if you buy x packs of this other
product we'll give you some gum and
eventually became the gum company rights
like it changes so often and too many
entrepreneurs are stuck on that has to
be this specific way and if you're not
listening to the market if you're not
combining what you love with what the
market wants you're never going to get
to the success that you're after
and so that insane stubbornness for the
vision but total flexibility for how you
accomplish it that's what's really
important as an entrepreneur
if you want more Evan check out the
first top ten rules video that was made
on me the link is right there next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
he's a former venture capitalist radio
host YouTube personality and
entrepreneur he sold his first company
in nineteen